hello youtube chess Louis and France
Gunjan here and today I'm very much
excited and something special for you
guys as you know that the World
Championship match 2018 is around the
corner which we all are eagerly waiting
for H and I can see very proudly that it
is my immense pleasure to announce that
with the collaboration with World Chess
Federation for GJ chess fans and
followers they have officially
introduced the promotional code the GJ
chess which gives you 25% discount on
their premium membership Wow isn't that
good news for all of us well stay tuned
as I will show you how you can get it by
end of this video but first Christian
comes to the mind well what are the
benefits for World Championship premium
membership well here you have it
number one the official HD video so
rather than watching only moves on the
board with sometimes bit boring
you can officially watch the live
footage of players like their behavior
their facial expression movement
reaction etc number two multiple camera
view you can watch the board as well as
players from different interesting
angles in fact from last World
Championship match as you can see here
they have introduced 360-degree view
which add more fun to the game number
three top G and commentary obviously
multiple chest legends and personality
have been invited to the World
Championship match and you can watch and
hear the game from their perspective
last but not least number four we have
the priority access to the
limited-edition merchandise so you can
visit their shop and get access of some
of the cool and unique chess as well as
non chest merchandise so that's it guys
what are you waiting for
just visit the wall chess calm and
become the Premium Member now remember
the chess world championship comes only
in two years time so don't miss out
grab this wonderful opportunity to get
your 25% discount and then watch enjoy
one of the all-time biggest chests world
championship event live lastly I just
want to show you how you can apply GJ
chess promotional code to get your
twenty five percent discount first of
all all you have to do is open any web
browser and then type in wall chess calm
and after that once you hit enter you
are able to see this page on your screen
now the interesting part is GJ chess
promotional code can be applied to not
only world championship match but you
can also apply this promotional code for
the 12-month Premium Membership and as
you can see the cost are very lower okay
I'm going to click on get my online
ticket and once I'll click that you are
able to see this page and you have to
slowly scroll down to reach this point
where it says that online access to the
match 2018 and these are all the
listings of benefits of Premium
Membership and after that we are going
to hit this blue bar saying get my
online ticket and once you click this we
have the final screen on the ball
here you can fill out all the necessary
details such as email password and your
credit card details and then comes to
the most important part promotional code
that's where I'm going to type Gigi Ches
all caps lock and then as you can see
once I'll hit the apply button right now
the cost is $20 but just within few
seconds you are going to see that now
the cost becomes $15
that means world chess has provide you
the 25% discount just go ahead and sign
in and you will able to see all this
wonderful stuff just for $15 well I hope
you like my Diwali gift feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
you